- ♪ WE WORK
THE HARD, HONEST JOB ♪
♪ WE ATE OUR CORN
OFF THE COBB ♪
♪ WE WERE
PROUD YOUNG AMERICANS ♪
♪ OOH YEAH
- HEY, MA.
I FINISHED PLOWING
THE FIELDS.
- [sniffles]
- I'M SORRY IT TOOK SO LONG.
I'LL GO FASTER NEXT TIME,
ALTHOUGH I DO LIKE
TO BE BY MYSELF.
WHAT'S WRONG, MA?
- OUR HOUSE
IS BEING FORECLOSED ON.
YOUR FATHER HAS GONE ON
DOWN TO THE BANK
TO BEG FOR MERCY.
- [sighs]
WELL...
I DID SEE THIS FLYER FOR
A TWO-POINT SHOOTING CONTEST.
I COULD ENTER IT,
AND IF WE WIN ENOUGH MONEY,
WE COULD SAVE THE HOUSE.
- YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR PA
SAYS ABOUT SHOOTING,
THAT SHOOTING'S FOR SHOW-OFFS.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
YOUR FATHER LOVES FUNDAMENTALS.
- BUT, MA, I GOT
THE SWEETEST STROKE AROUND.
ASK ANY OF THE COWS.
[crack]
OW, MY BACK.
- OH, LARRY, LIE DOWN.
- [groans]
- OH, LARRY,
I BELIEVE IN YOU.
I CAN DRIVE YOU TO
THE TWO-POINT SHOOTING CONTEST.
- [sighs]
TAPE ME UP.
[upbeat music]
- ♪ WE DIDN'T SLOUCH
WHEN WE WALKED ♪
♪ WE DIDN'T CUSS
WHEN WE TALKED ♪
♪ WE WERE
PROUD YOUNG AMERICANS ♪
♪ OOH YEAH
[indistinct chatter]
- HELLO, MRS. THOMPSON.
- AREN'T YOU GONNA
GET TO STRETCHING?
- I DON'T STRETCH.
STRETCHING'S FOR SHOW-OFFS.
- MY BALL PLAYING
DOES THE TALKING FOR ME, SO...
- [chuckles]
- [blows whistle]
[funk music]
♪
[cheers and applause]
[blows whistle]
- COME ON, LARRY,
YOU LAZY BUM.
YOU GOOD-FOR-NOTHING.
NEVER DONE ANYTHING
IN YOUR LIFE.
WHY DON'T YOU GO
AND DO SOMETHING WITH YOURSELF
INSTEAD OF JUST SITTING AROUND
AND BEING A LAZY "B"?
[dramatic music]
[back cracking]
♪
[cheers and applause]
[somber music]
♪
- YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR PA
SAYS ABOUT SHOOTING,
THAT SHOOTING'S FOR SHOW-OFFS.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH YOUR FATHER
LOVES FUNDAMENTALS.
- COME ON, LARRY,
YOU LAZY BUM.
YOU GOOD-FOR-NOTHING.
NEVER DID ANYTHING
IN YOUR LIFE.
♪
[funk music]
[cheers and applause]
- OH, MY BOY.
- I DIDN'T WIN THE MONEY
TO SAVE THE FARM.
- NO HOUSE COULD BE WORTH
MORE THAN THE PRIDE I HAVE
IN YOUR FUNDAMENTALS.
- THANK YOU, SIR.
- WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO LIVE IN THE CAR NOW.
- YOU GOT A LOT OF TALENT,
LARRY BIRD.
- MAKE NO MISTAKE,
MAGIC JOHNSON,
I WILL [bleep] END YOU.
[chuckles]
- ♪ WE SAID OUR PRAYERS
BEFORE BED ♪
♪ WE DIDN'T SEX TILL WE WED
♪ WE WERE
PROUD YOUNG AMERICANS ♪
♪ OOH YEAH